the next two questions dasani and Babu
lo are talking about how basically how
do you find investors what's the process
of finding an investor what direction
you take you're trying to get capital
how do you go and actually find those
two investors your business yeah I think
probably the most difficult time is when
you start up so you know you're
bootstrapping a business I think once
you get to sort of critical mass you've
got revenues million two three four five
minutes there's a whole kind of network
of growth capital venture capitalists
out there but in reality you know looked
at some data the other day about eighty
to ninety percent of the startups are
funded through people like us starting
businesses yourselves so that's your own
life savings remove within your home
your credit card maybe getting a loan
from the bank stuff like that and then
the other you know factories all the
friends and family stuff although you
don't want to take the friends and
family money you've got to agree some
parameters of this stuff because you
don't want to go on vacation with them
and every night is like an investment it
you know you've got a you've got to make
sure you do friends and families you
have delineation between the investment
and your relationship and you know all
these things you've got to tell them you
can make money you might get ten times
or you know I work 80 hours a week and
it doesn't work out they got to
understand that but then the other
things I'd say is that's the obvious one
see your self friends and family then
there's a whole world out there of
crowdsourcing and there's the indigo
goes the Kickstarter's all these sort of
guys out there as well and turn to
crowdsourcing no I saw prediction send
the crowdsourcing market would actually
exceed in terms of the capital deployed
I think it's by 2017 the VC marketplace
so we're seeing that whole impact of
digital and social around crowdsources
our very way to go so the office places
as well you know let's start if you're
if you're up in Massachusetts or you
around Kansas you could go down to your
local why the state or
you can go on the federal websites
there's loads of ways to get help around
if I capital if you're in a minority
group there's specific things done for
you know minority agencies and upon the
Commerce there's loads of stuff out in
New York and you stay I think nice star
where they connect you with a network of
entrepreneurs there's a whole load of
range of Andrew investors and the other
thing i'd say evan is just to sort of
throw away all the angel investors i
know a regular guys they've done very
well they've been very successful
they're very approachable so one of the
kind of things in our heads and voices
to prevent us being successful is then I
couldn't pick up the phone to someone I
couldn't email someone but you never
know you know if there's someone you
really respect tues created a business
in your industry with a lot of domain
experience I'd say try and reach out to
them because they could be an amazing
and angel investor and they might you
know look at you at the age of 27 28 and
say I really am I type guys got a great
story disruptive innovator and I'm not
any angel investor I could be my mentor
in that business so I think there's a
lot of ways around there to find the
investment beyond to a friends and
family and yourself and where
traditional things I think go digital go
crowdsourcing but also just kind of use
your common sense have no fear and be
prepared to pick up to the phone to
people but to Evans point the more
expensive you go in terms your search
for capsule the more time it takes and
that's a distraction from running the
business for clarification for those are
you guys watching a lot of the
crowdsourcing is a fantastic way to
raise money but you're often and usually
not giving up a piece of your company
but if you go to Kickstarter it's more
like marketing right you're you want to
pitch this new product that you want to
launch we need a million dollars to do
it or ten thousand dollars to do it
you're pre-selling and you're giving
them bonuses but you don't lose a chunk
of your company there are other
crowdsourcing options where you are
giving up your looking for angels
basically but majority of it is not
actually giving up an equity position
your business so it's definitely
something worth looking at because if
you don't have to give up equity it stay
you insane amount of money down the road
in terms of finding investors i think to
stevens point most of the angel
investors are regular guys and guys and
girls ladies and most of them don't go
to angel investment meetings most of
them are not part of an angel investment
group most of them find their deals
through their connections to their
networks and so I would want to be
telling my story the people who are
connected into those networks great
places to start with our accountants and
lawyers because they deal with business
people on an ongoing basis it's their
job to be connected to a bunch of these
guys so if they like your story they
could probably introduce the assembly
who could probably help you out at least
have a conversation with you